In this lesson, we're going to talk about managing levels and how we can maintain and
create an environment in which we can have better workflows.
So let's get started.
The topics we'll cover is editing levels and why, and separating items and how that works.
So editing levels and why.
Most times when levels are simple, they can be managed in one persistent level.
So oftentimes that is not the case, as others will need to edit specific items.
So in your team, they may be a group of people that are working with lighting, maybe working
with the effects, maybe working with the geo.
The level system in Unreal allows many people to work on a project and edit different aspects
such as lights and geo, as well as effects without interfering with other items.
This system keeps things clean and easier to maintain.
But many people can also get confused on the difference between layers and working with
our level system.
Layers, you can think of it as a typical layer system that you would see in 3D Studio Max
and Maya.
We won't get too much into this, but it works exactly the same way where you can just manage
things more to that particular work area that you're in.
And you can populate this any way that you need.
But we're going to mainly focus on levels, which is a little bit more powerful because
here, or actually I should say quite more powerful, because here we can actually load
other levels that we've created that have separate pieces that have been built by someone
else.
Like someone could build, hey, I built this new city, this new building, these new rocks
and terrain, and I'm going to give you this level.
So they can immigrate that level to you.
And then now you may be the one person in charge or multiple people charge of assembling
this.
You can now go in here and say, hey, I'm going to now edit and add that existing level in
here.
So you can add existing.
And that's kind of what I did here.
And if you look down below, you'll see the spires level.
It is actually loaded here.
And if I hit this eyeball icon, you'll see that most of those, except for a few that
I just plopped in recently, will actually disappear.
So most of our spires are gone.
And that makes it a lot easier.
So if you're that way, you can actually bring in what someone else has worked on.
And at the same time, you can make some edits without affecting anybody else's stuff.
You can say, hey, I'm going to make this current or I'm going to work on this particular one.
In this case, we're working off the persistent level.
Now one thing I do want to mention, though, when working with levels, when it comes to
your lighting, make sure that your lighting, for the most part, is in your persistent level.
This is actually a really good practice.
Now is it a hard rule?
Not all the time.
Sometimes you can nest these in a different areas, but you do want to be careful if you
nest them too deeply.
You can make it have a disconnect when it comes to like baking your lights or even working
with ray tracing.
So you want to be careful of that and be aware of that situation.
So as long as you're organized and keep things in a clean fashion and make sure you don't
put these things in too many sub levels, you should be OK.
So also I'll notice I'll point out to you when it comes to your streaming method.
So you change streaming method.
Right now we're set to blueprint.
That makes it easy for us to just bring this item in here.
If you have it always loaded, just make sure you're aware of everything that's in that
scene.
If there's extra lights that are in that particular level that you're bringing in, you make sure
that that's removed.
So you're only using the lighting that's in your persistent level or whatever you're using
for lighting.
So there is no conflict.
So when you're baking, there isn't any weirdness going on.
There isn't double lights or double items.
So organization again is super key to this.
You'll see right here there's a save level icon.
There's a save level and you also can change the level color so you can actually keep things
a little bit more organized as well as create new folders for any items that you want to
populate.
So just keep those things in mind.
And that's really beneficial.
If I say I grab this select type and I said, hey, you know what?
I want to add that select type.
So just when I hit the eyeball button, everything is gone except for that.
I can right click and I can go to move selected actors to level so I can move that right to
that level if I needed to.
You can deselect actors.
You can convert external level actors.
So there's a lot of different options here, which makes it a lot easier for you.
You can even lock them if you need to or even make it current.
Now this is important to consider these things because having this edit control is really
beneficial for your full production.
Again, you can see you can add existing and you can even create new.
When you create new, you literally are making a brand new scene and you can populate it
really quickly.
And in that new level, you will immediately have access to it.
But just make sure again, housekeeping.
You know exactly what's in that level and what's coming into your existing production.
So I'm going to hit cancel here.
And we can see again, separating items.
So there's two ways you can add the levels.
And I'll reemphasize this because it can be kind of confusing in the very beginning
when people try to understand how this works.
You select your geolights or et cetera, what you wish to separate in a persistent level
and go to levels, create new with selected actors.
You can also load other outside levels, as mentioned before, to a persistent level and
stream them via blueprint to call on it when needed or always loaded if you need it in
the level right away while you work.
Now the benefit of streaming levels, I'm going to point this out, of doing it through a blueprint
you could also cycle through levels, lighting scenarios.
Now most of that's a little bit geared more towards pre-visualization because most of
the time when you're in a virtual set, you kind of determine exactly the lighting that
you want because you want to make sure that everything's linking correctly.
And when you're flipping through your persistent level, that can be a bit of an issue.
So just keep that in mind.
But having that blueprint allows you if you did need to cycle through a lighting system,
it's not possible.
It just takes a bit of work.
You can actually do that within your environment, but it's better to change the light that you
have existing on that case because there's a lot more involved, especially if you're
working with such things as your tracking, your identifying, your linking your stage
to what you're doing in your Unreal environment.
So just keep those things in mind.
There's a lot of work involved.
But for the most part, you want to use your lighting.
So if you are deciding to do blueprint and switching between streaming levels, that leans
more towards pre-visualization.
And then when it comes to the lighting, like I mentioned before, try to keep your linings
not so much on the sub levels if you can.
Keeping it on your persistent level is a bit more ideal because then you have quick access
to it.
If you run into any problems, you make sure that things are linking cleanly.
You're at the top level of everything.
And it's not a golden rule because there are ways around that.
It's just this is different from a game environment.
This is more of a virtual production environment.
So keep those things in mind.